in these trying times when our nation is
so divided the only thing that can bring
us all together is kicking one of the
two presidential candidates off the
ballot yes that'll do it now our nation
can heal God Bless
America yes a few months ago I told you
that there was a possibility that Donald
Trump would be ruled ineligible for the
presidency because of Section 3 of the
14th Amendment and now one state has
actually booted him from the ballot on
December 19th 3 years to the day after
Donald Trump sent this Infamous tweet
announcing a mass protest be there it
will be wild the Colorado Supreme Court
held that Trump is disqualified from
holding the office of President because
he participated in an Insurrection as a
result the Court ruled that Trump cannot
be listed on the Republican presidential
primary ballot in Colorado this decision
opens up a big can of worms for the
embattled US Supreme Court will it
overrule the Colorado Supreme Court how
will it structure its decision what
precedent might this set for other
states and of course what's also going
on with Michigan and Maine As Trump gets
kicked off another ble bot today we're
going to talk about the ramifications of
this decision but first what in the
world just happened in Colorado well in
October a group of Colorado electors
eligible to vote in the Republican
presidential primary including both
registered Republican and unaffiliated
voters filed a petition in the district
court for the County of Denver asking
the court to rule that the former
president Trump may not appear on the
Colorado Republican presidential primary
ballot the plaintiffs asserted that he
quote wasn't eligible under Section 3
because he engaged in Insurrection on
January 6 2021 after swearing an as
president to support the US Constitution
The District Court conducted a 5-day
trial and then found by clear and
convincing evidence that Trump engaged
in an Insurrection as those terms are
used in section three of the 14th
Amendment however the district court
concluded section three does not apply
to the president because the presidency
is not in office and therefore the
president is not an officer of the
United States the plaintiffs appealed
and the Colorado Supreme Court partially
overturned the district court decision
finding that Trump committed
Insurrection and that he was an officer
of of the United States the first issue
was whether the state had jurisdiction
to decide whether presidential candidate
had participated in an Insurrection and
was therefore disqualified from the
ballot now you might legitimately wonder
why in the world we would want 50
different standards for how an election
is administered well take that up with
the founding fathers since the
Constitution delegates to the states the
authority to prescribe the times places
and manner of holding Congressional
elections the States retain the power to
regulate their own elections now I'm not
going to do a deep dive into the
applicable Colorado statutes because we
have a lot of material related to the
Federal Constitution and the Supreme
Court is not going to care that much
about the actual Colorado election law
issues here so let's move on to the text
of section three of the 14th Amendment
to the Federal Constitution which reads
quote no person shall be a senator or
representative in Congress or elector of
president and vice president or hold any
office civil or military under the
United States or any state who having
previously taken an oath as a member of
Congress or as an officer of the United
States or as a member of any state
legislature or as an executive or
judicial officer of any state to support
the Constitution of the United States
shall have engaged in an Insurrection or
Rebellion against the same or given Aid
or Comfort to the enemies thereof but
Congress May by a vote of 2third of each
house remove such disability section
three was added to the Constitution
after the Civil War when Northern
Republicans were outraged at the
prospect of Southerners who seceded from
the Union returning to hold positions of
power in the same government that they
tried to destroy this was their way of
saying if you ever participated in
Insurrection in this country you aren't
eligible to serve as an officer of the
United States but they didn't Define all
the terms that they used in Section 3 so
the court had to do it for them so the
Colorado courts first had to determine
whether Trump had participated in an
Insurrection when the 14th amendment was
ratified there was an assumption that
everyone knew what an Insurrection
looked like because there had just been
a civil war it seems that Congress would
block anyone that it felt had
participated in the Confederacy but in
the absence of a Civil War what are we
to do well the Colorado Supreme Court
started with the dictionary definition
of the word ins ction Miriam Webster
says it's an act or instance of
revolting against civil or political
Authority or against an established
government or an act or instance of
rising up physically and the court
agreed that Insurrection for purposes of
section three has to include a concerted
and public use of force or threat of
force by a group of people to hinder or
prevent the US government from taking
the actions necessary to accomplish a
peaceful transition of power in this
country and the Colorado courts
concluded that whatever definition
you're using it would apply in this
scenario right after January 6
Republicans quickly recognized that what
had happened met the general definition
of insurrection just like their
Reconstruction Era ancestors here's
Majority Leader Mi McConnell on January
7th 2021 using the same definition as
the Colorado Court was a violent
Insurrection for the purpose of trying
to prevent the peaceful transfer of
power after a legitimately certified
election from one Administration to the
next Trump's lawyers declined to offer a
definition of insurrection instead
arguing that an Insurrection is more
than a riot but less than a rebellion
the court agreed that quote an
Insurrection Falls along a spectrum of
related conduct but no Authority
supports the position taken by President
Trump's Council an oral argument that
insurrectionary conduct must involve a
particular length of time or geographic
location the bottom line is that there
has to be a group of people who use
violence in public way and violence also
has to be directed towards achieving
some kind of public purpose a private
act or even a conspiracy to commits a
crime doesn't rise to the level of
insurrection and the required force or
threat of force doesn't require
Bloodshed nor does it require those
involved to be highly organized at the
insurrections Inception and you can see
how this definition might include
Trump's actions before and during
January 6 Mike Pence is going to have to
come through for us and if he
doesn't that will be a sad day for our
country Pence cave we're going to drag
through the streets you politicians are
going to get drugged through the streets
and during the events of January 6 the
court said quote it is Undisputed that a
large group of people forcibly entered
the capital and that this action was so
formidable that law enforcement
officials on site could not control it
the court slammed team Trump for arguing
that no one was armed on January 6 since
the mob was armed with a wide array of
weapons the oathkeeper stored a cache of
weapons for a qrf or quick reaction
force that would respond to the capital
armed if president Trump were to quote
declare an Insurrection and to call us
up as the militia many of the writers
also stole objects from the building and
even the from the police including metal
rod Shields and batons and then the
court considered whether Trump really
engaged in an Insurrection for purposes
of Section 3 since Trump wasn't with the
mob when they entered the Capitol
Building there wasn't really much
precedent so the court looked at treason
cases in 1807 chief justice Marshall
explained that quote all those who
perform any part however minute or
however remote from the scene of action
and who actually leaded in the general
conspiracy are to be considered traitors
the Colorado Court held that engaged
requires an overt act and voluntary act
done with the intent of aiding or
furthering the common unlawful purpose
and concluded that Trump engaged in an
Insurrection here the court notes that
Trump laid the groundwork as early as
August of 2020 when he said the election
would be rigged against him in September
he refused to commit to a peaceful
transfer of power the court emphasized
that Trump and his supporters were
United in the purpose of stopping
Congress from certifying the election
quote the mob was coordinated and
demonstrated a Unity of purpose they
marched through the capital building
chanting and manner that made clear that
they were seeking to inflict violence
against members of Congress and vice
president Pence and upon breaching the
capital the mob immediately pursued its
intended target the certification of the
presidential election and reached the
House and Senate chambers within minutes
of entering the building uh the mob
achieved its objective at least
temporarily quote this breach caused
both the House and Senate to adjourn
halting the Electoral certification
process in addition much of the mob's ey
which included threats of physical
violence was directed at vice president
Pence who in his role as president of
the Senate was constitutionally tasked
with carrying out the Electoral count in
other words the mob wasn't on a tourist
trip taking selfies as some Republicans
have recently insisted they wanted to
stop the peaceful transfer of power now
if you ever get kicked off a ballot then
you'll need a good lawyer but if you
want a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've been in a car
crash suffered from sexual harassment or
are dealing with social security or
workers comp issues we can represent you
or help find you the right attorney who
can it's so important to talk to an
attorney right away so you don't lose
your chance for full recovery and
maximize your options so just click on
the Link in the description for free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is below the
Colorado Supreme Court agreed with the
district court that Trump was no
innocent bystander in these events he
recruited quote proud boys the
oathkeepers and the three centers Q
andon conspiracy theorists and white
nationalists to travel to Washington DC
on January 6th the court concluded that
Trump was aware of and sanctioned
violence the court suggested that the
mob never would have assembled if Trump
had not invited them quote at this point
the record established that President
Trump's plan was that when congress met
to certify the election results on
January 6th vice president Pence could
reject the true electors who voted for
President Biden and certify a slate of
fake electors supporting president Trump
or he could return the slates to the
states for further proceedings now the
Colorado Supreme Court overturned the
lower Court's decision that the
president is not an officer of the
United States now the district court
concluded that the presidency is not an
office civil or military under the
United States for two reasons first the
court noted that the presidency is not
specifically mentioned in section three
though Senators representatives and
presidential electors are the court
found it unlikely that the presidency
would be included in a catchall of any
office civil or military second the
court found it compelling that an
earlier draft of the section
specifically included the presidency
suggesting that the drafters intended to
omit the presidency in the version that
it passed but the state supreme court
concluded that the specifics of that
change don't prove that there wasn't an
intent to exclude the presidency from
the covered offices this part of the
majority opinion focuses on the spirit
of the law rather than the letter
because it concludes that it would have
been logically absurd for Section 3's
drafter to exclude the president from
the list of people who shouldn't be
allowed to hold elective office if they
participated in an Insurrection quote
the drafters of section three were
motivated by a sense of betrayal that is
by the existence of a broken oath not by
the type of officer who broke it all of
us understand the meaning of the third
section Senator John Sherman stated it
includes those men who have once taken
an oath of office to support the
Constitution of the United States and
have violated that oath in Spirit by
taking up arms against the government of
the United States are to be deprived for
a time at least of holding office the
majority opinion also makes a textual
argument by finding that quote the
Constitution refers to the presidency as
an officer 25 times the court also notes
that the constitution refers to the
presidency as an office under the United
States in several contexts that seem to
support the conclusion that the
presidency is such an office and as
another example they cite the
impeachment clause which reads that
Congress can impose as a consequence of
impeachment a disqualification to hold
and enjoy any office of Honor trust or
profit under the United States if the
presidency is not in office under the
United States then anyone impeached
including president could nonetheless go
on to serve as president uh this reading
is nonsensical as recent impeachments
demonstrate the Court's point is that it
would have been weird if the impeachment
proceedings against Trump and Bill
Clinton would have resulted in their
removal from office and disqualification
to hold any future office except for the
presidency the Colorado Court concluded
the quote president Trump undertook all
these actions to Aid and further a
common unlawful purpose that he himself
conceived and set in motion prevent
Congress from certifying the 2020
presidential election and stop the
peaceful transfer of power the Court
held that Trump is barred from the
primary ballot although that decision
stayed through the Supreme Court's
review now all seven of the Colorado
justices were Democrats and the result
was four votes to three the three
dissenting justices also raised
substantive issues that may get the
attention of the Supreme Court some of
the dissenting justices said that the
court didn't give Trump enough due
process now what constitutes sufficient
due process to disqualify someone from
the ballot that's an open question
should the person have the same
safeguards they would in a criminal
trial or should the process be more like
a civil case we don't really know here
in this particular case there was a
5-day trial in the district court where
both sides presented testimony and the
court came to a conclusion Trump was
represented and filed briefs outlining
his position the parties called
Witnesses and many third parties filed
supplemental amicus briefs to help the
Court decide but on the other hand the
hearing lacked Discovery neither side
could subpoena documents or compel
Witnesses and it was decided by a judge
rather than a jury the dissenting
justices also said that maybe there
should be an independent procedure
something akin to a criminal trial
before a court rules that a person can't
appear on the ballot the
disqualification Clause is frustratingly
silent on whether there must be an
independent proceeding so the question
is whether Section 3 is really
self-executing now A law is
self-executing if it is immediately
effective without further action
legislation or legal steps the Supreme
Court has never decided this issue but
chief justice solman Chase apped on it
while he was a circuit Justice for
Virginia in 1854 Chase was going to
Pride over the treason trial of
Jefferson Davis now that trial never
happened because President Andrew
Johnson gave him a pardon but Chase
allegedly told Davis's lawyer that he
viewed section three as a criminal
punishment and that if Davis was
disqualified he would not face a
criminal trial then in 1869 Chase
decided a case called inray Griffin uh
Caesar Griffin had been sentenced to a
two-year prison sentence for assault by
state judge who happened to be a former
Confederate officer Griffin argued that
the judge was disqualified under section
three and that it was self-executing
Justice Chase disagreed here he held
that the legislation by Congress
providing for removal was necessary to
give effect to the prohibition of
Section 3 and without such legislation
the judge was entitled to continue in
his position now remember when I said
earlier about 50 states and 50 different
rules well the Michigan Supreme Court
has ruled that Trump's candidacy was a
political question and Michigan law
didn't give the Secretary of State the
right to keep him off the ballot but in
Maine the legislator delegated authority
to determine candidate qualifications to
the Secretary of State so main voters
filed three administrative challenges to
Trump's presence on the primary ballot
and the main Secretary of State shenna
Bellow held a hearing uh where Trump's
lawyers and the challengers argued the
merits of disqualification and Bellow
has now ruled that Trump is ineligible
to be listed on Maine's primary ballot
now the decision uh was made by the
state official rather than a court but
the rationale is pretty similar to
Colorado Trump tried to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power on January 6
the riot was an Insurrection and section
three bars Trump from Office Bellow's
reli on the testimony of a historian who
said that some quote members of Congress
believed the presidency was in office
when the amendment was being debated as
did contemporaries outside of Congress
including those who sought to keep
Jefferson Davis from the presidency
therefore Bellow found it quote
implausible that the drafters of section
three chose to exempt the highest office
in our government from an amendment
designed to keep Confederates from
positions of power bow said quote I am
mindful that no secretary of state has
ever deprived a presidential candidate
of ballot access based on section three
of the 14th Amendment I am also mindful
however that no presidential candidate
has ever before engaged in Insurrection
the main decision is pitched directly at
the Supreme Court's conservative Wing
which has ruled that the court must
prioritize the normal and ordinary usage
of words rather than secret or technical
meanings that would not have been known
to the ordinary citizens in the founding
generation and as Bell notes that
language comes from the District of
Columbia versus heler where the Court
held that the second amendment
guarantees an individual right to
possess Firearms independent of service
in state militia now it's almost certain
that Trump will appeal that decision so
the question is will the Supreme Court
take these cases on well that's pretty
likely while the Supreme Court has just
recently turned down Jack Smith's
request for hearing the immunity cases
directly without waiting for the court
of appeals it's hard to picture that the
Supreme Court would allow States courts
to have the final word on the meaning of
section three of the 14th Amendment and
most commentators are assuming that the
court will overturn the rulings and let
Trump run for president in one way or
another but the way they do it it's
going to be of course very fascinating
but you can also be certain that the
court will claim that politics had
nothing to do with their reasoning and
you can already see how this case is
scrambling the normal political and
legal valences that would exists in a
case like this with many Democrats using
principles of originalism or textualism
to look at the text and original intent
of the 14th Amendment to disqualified
Trump from the ballot and also many
Republicans explicitly bringing politics
into things saying that we should ignore
the textual and original meaning of the
14th Amendment and look to the political
ramifications and constitutional law
professor Steve Vlad has summarized the
political and legal ironies that this
case brings up on the excellent It's
Complicated podcast I realize this is
this is a weird argument for a
constitutional law professor to make but
these are weird times I mean I I you
know I tweeted this Tuesday night and
knew I was going to get in trouble for
it and did but I think you can believe
at the same time that President Trump
engaged an Insurrection and that he
ought to be disqualified from ever
holding office again and also believe
given the you know Republican party's um
casual relationship with truth and facts
and evidence and um widespread
endorsement of January 6 related and
election related conspiracy theories
that it's actually better for our
politics if Trump loses having been on
the ballot in all 50 states then if he
loses having been kept off the ballot in
a handful of states by this you know
maybe correct Asha but novel um
application of a constitutional
provision that very few people had heard
about um before 2021 and so you know I I
think what what this really is and I
mean you you know this as well as anyone
is you know the the dirty little secret
is that law is not an absolute um right
law is part of a is part of a mush that
politics is also part of and I think
that the Supreme Court probably was
hoping against hope that they didn't get
dragged into this mess um and that maybe
the color of Supreme Court like the
Minnesota Supreme Court found a way to
not keep Trump off the ballot and to me
the real headline of what happened on
Tuesday is now I think the Supreme Court
has to step in against you know not not
wanting to and in a way in which there's
almost no you know obvious win right for
the Supreme Court yeah it's weird times
in the world and politicians are getting
doxed and swatted left and right all for
their political beliefs which is
terrible never SWAT someone it's a
felony go to jail but it's possible
because so much of your personal data
like your personal address is online
which is why I use today's sponsor incog
incog removes your personal data from
online data Brokers they reach out and
make sure it's taken down if these data
Brokers object which I've seen incog
will take care of that too it's amazing
now I don't know if you've ever Googled
yourself but there are major people
search sites out there that probably
have your personal contact info too it
might be because of a data hack but
sometimes our friends and family even
provide that info voluntarily by
clicking on one of those boxes when they
sign up for websites or apps these sites
provide in-depth records including
information such as home addresses
contact details license plate numbers
family members financial information and
even religious and political beliefs
these sites can expose you to a wide
range of dangers from scams to identity
theft to online harassment and stalking
now it was very important for me that I
not appear on those sites and incog took
that information down and not only
doesn't cogni help with your online
personal info being taken down but it
can also stop marketing efforts I've
seen a huge uction in the amount of spam
emails that I get spam calls and spam
texts and it's no surprise why I was
getting all of the spam according to the
2022 annual data breach report by the
identity theft Resource Center the
number of victims has gone up nearly 41%
from 2021 I was constantly getting
notified that my information was part of
a data breach so when that happens incog
fights for you to have your personal
data taken down from data broker believe
me so many people have it tackling this
yourself would be nearly impossible but
that's where incog comes in incog fights
on your behalf to to remove your
personal data from data Brokers and
deals with any objections from their
side all you have to do is create an
account and give them approval to work
on your behalf incognet conducts
repeated ongoing removals because even
if the Brokers remove your data once
they can collect it again and then use
it again incog makes sure that your
personal information stays off the
market for good and it was fascinating
for me to look at my own dashboard and
realize that I'm on hundreds of data
Brokers lists here's part of my personal
incog dashboard it shows that these
three sites had data on me that was
rated 10 out of 10 on incognit
sensitivity scale these Brokers had data
included my contacts financial data and
Health Data it was terrifying to see
exactly how many Brokers had my data but
it was really fun to watching cogy get
them to delete that info one by one so
if online privacy is important to you
give in cogne a try you can click on the
link below to get 60% off incog when you
use the code legal eagle so again to get
an exclusive 60% off discount just click
on the link that's on screen or down in
the description use the code legal eagle
after that click on this link over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court